hey guys
so i'm here with uh caroline mitchell
today
hi guys and i just went around the show
because we were hanging out and uh
i was like this girl's really hot she's
gonna be on my show
and here i am so today i'm not gonna
talk about some crazy topic
i just want to talk about her look at
her holy [ __ ]
hi guys yeah okay so she's a model
and damn i'm telling you right now i was
looking at her photos earlier
click the link below um insert here i'll
put the i'll put the link there
anything you anything you say i'm gonna
do is just that simple that's that's the
thing about
beautiful woman with me like beautiful
like if a beautiful woman
says something it's like it's like god's
making a command right now
abusive really yeah no but i'm okay with
being abused
you can abuse me as much as you want
caroline i get that a lot
i'd imagine i'll be one of the many men
who's like please abuse me
that is going too far now so caroline i
want to get to know you
okay the world wants to get to know you
do you
yeah i don't think you do come on cheer
for me come on
i see you there sitting in your computer
he's touching himself
i [ __ ] know can you get him out of
here please jesus
yeah well maybe he's touching it to me
don't laugh at that that could be very
sincere okay so why did i want to become
a model we're from the city where every
pretty girl thinks she can become a
model and she is a model
and she should model and uh you know
post all these pictures of herself
with a camera it's really not that
simple at all so i actually didn't want
to become a model at all because i was
really self-conscious that everybody was
going to think oh she's that girl who
wants to become a model
who peaked in high school after high
school i was working in fashion
a lot and everybody had clothing lines
asked me to be a fit model for this or
do catalog work for that
so then i started getting pulled in and
i was like if i'm getting approached for
work when i'm not trying maybe i should
try
and then i quit my fashion job and i got
an agent
after a couple months of trying really
hard and i got a nice big billboard on
sunset
and ventura and like all over and that
felt really good
and so i'm just kind of trying to keep
going it's hard work i need a bigger
agency
someone who can handle all this you know
what i'm saying
oh i can i can't handle all that no no
no
i need like four boyfriends for my four
different personalities
i will gladly eat one of the four now
taking applications yeah
i don't care if i get to hug you for
more than a
second that right there will make my
dick
let's show you some pictures of caroline
okay we're gonna look at some sexy
photos of caroline mitchell sexy
so let's talk about this photo wow
that is very like that's intimidating
that like you're so confident my knees
are getting weak just looking at
those camps i just realized i don't need
porn anymore
these photos just look at them holy hey
i am clothed
she's she's clothed but the damn sort of
okay so you got this photo right here
that's my facebook profile pic oh hell
yeah that is
that i'm afraid to be around you right
now
just because i feel so shy you are
significantly better looking than i am
oh my god i thought you were gonna say
significantly better looking there than
i am
i'll be in my trailer in person you are
uh you're
funny and you're uh you're delight to be
around
but you're you're even way better
looking in person
you ever get that feeling where you see
a girl in the photo you're like
damn that [ __ ] be hot and then you like
check her out in person you're like shh
butterface not this time around or in
other words like butter personality
oh yeah that makes sense but you know
what i'm saying yeah
you're hot you can say whatever give me
some man perspective upon this what do
you what do you mean man
i don't know that photo can make you
easily think of a lot of different
things in your mind
of what this is sexual things
i mean i like it i like the uh
definition in my muscles
and like you're very confident and then
the the pictures are looking directly at
the camera i feel like you're staring
into my soul
with my piercing green eyes that's what
it is let's see what else
that was for a music video actually it's
like a clothing line
what is it called
that is not a symbol for anything it was
like a releasing
line video with music on it yeah even
with full body makeup
i'm like dang what would sex be
like if you got that question popping up
in my mind
theme that means you're doing something
right well
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah uh i have a new
obsession
and it's you it's begun get ready for me
to just
download all your photos secretly of
course
no i'm gonna publicize my love for you
caroline
what would be the most awkward modeling
experience you've ever had um when i was
doing the masters of sex billboard
they didn't take their time to
individually
put makeup on us they had me two girls
and two or three guys
all naked in front of each other
airbrushing each other did any of them
have a boner
no no really you know did that
disappoint you
well not really because i am happy that
they're being professional
if we ever went to the beach together i
would not be professional well you don't
have to be professional because you just
that's your show you tell it like it is
that's true but when you're on like a
set
at milk studios with showtime executives
you expect people not to pop their wood
up and say hey
you know what kind of penises have you
seen my friend they sprout hands and
they go okay
i think your application for being my
boyfriend has been tonight
you don't sprout hands and say hey